call your friends you love the ones who
you know that if you called them at
three o'clock in the morning they would
answer the phone
and if they called you at three o'clock
in the morning you would be there for
them do not do this with family
do not do this with siblings do not do
this with your spouse
it doesn't work those relationships are
too close do it with the friends you
love
and ask them the simple question why are
we friends
and they're gonna look at you like
you're crazy because the part of the
brain that controls feelings
and behavior doesn't control language in
other words it's hard to put into words
ironically you stop asking the question
why because the question why is an
emotional question
and it elicits emotional responses like
you ask your kids why are you home late
shut up dad but if you say what were you
doing that you're home late that'll
answer the question
right so you after your friends say i
don't why are you asking me this
you switch to what questions come on
what is it about me
what specifically is it about me that i
know that you would be there for me no
matter what
and they're going to hem and han it's
going to be very difficult for them and
they're going to struggle
don't help them don't let anybody else
help them you have to let them go
through the uncomfortable process
and you have to play devil's advocate so
they'll say things like
i don't know you're funny you're smart i
can rely on you
and you say good that's the definition
of a friend you have that with all your
friends
what specif specifically is it about me
that i know you would be there for me no
matter what
and they're going to go through this
process of and you're going to say good
that's the definition of a close friend
what
you're going to keep keep at them and
eventually
they'll give up eventually they'll give
up and they'll stop describing you
and they'll start describing themselves
and this is what my friend said to me
they said i don't know simon
all i know is that i can just sit in a
room with you i don't even have to talk
to you and i feel inspired
and i got goosebumps in fact i'm getting
them right now
right so what they did is they
articulated my value in their lives and
i had an emotional response
so you'll get to the point where they'll
say something that you will either get
goosebumps or you're well up with tears
or something will happen you will have
an emotional response that's the part of
the brain the olympic brain
that controls those emotions you won't
get the exact words of your why
but you'll get in the ballpark and my
friends what you'll find is if you do
with multiple friends
you'll get very similar if not the exact
same answer
because the value you have in their
lives is the same
it's you so it's a fun way to find your
[Music]
why
you